hey you guys welcome back to the
flickers of fear show so as it's getting
closer and closer to christmas
uh i decided as i said you know the
whole month of december we're doing kind
of like winter themed horror movies but
i decided uh on this show that i would
actually since we're getting closer to
christmas that i would do something
that's actually
kind of more uh i don't want to say it's
a straightforward christmas movie it is
actually set on christmas and there is
like a christmasy vibe to it in the
sense of you know it taking place on
christmas and that being kind of a
component of the story but it's a
christmas movie that
a lot of people don't talk about as
being a christmas movie i guess because
it's primarily i mean the way that it
was i guess marketed or the way that
it's um
you know cover looks and everything like
that it's kind of more
of a satanic type uh omen type thing
except funny uh this is the day of the
beast from
1995. uh also known as la dia de la
bestia if you know i'm sure i'm
pronouncing that wrong
so uh this movie i had been hearing so
much about this one i feel like this is
one it's a spanish film
and this is one that kind of maybe goes
under a lot of people's radar even
though the guy who made it uh alex dilla
iglesia is a very very well-known uh
filmmaker in spain
and honestly this movie here
uh it was actually a very important
movie in spanish horror cinema and
actually ended up winning like six goya
awards uh in 1996 and sort of
reinvigorated uh spain's horror you know
output because prior to this there
hadn't really been much of anything you
know since back in the days of the 70s
and stuff so uh so easily one of the
most important spanish films of the
1990s and i do kind of feel like it's
not even among horror fans
i don't know i kind of feel like it does
have a cult following but maybe not as
big as it deserves
uh the nice thing now though uh because
i kind of feel like this movie was
really hard to get hold of for a very
long time but now it seems like it's
very very easy to see i watched on
shutter shutter has it uh 2b has it for
free i believe you can watch it for free
if you have amazon prime uh voodoo has
it for free so you can kind of see this
everywhere and i think that's really
good because i think a lot of people
will really really dig this movie and i
think it's one it's a black comedy like
it's a horror movie uh you know having
to do with satanism and stuff but it's
also a black comedy and like a almost
like a satire so so how you feel about
that it kind of reminded me and i'm not
i guess i'm not the only person that
that thought this but it kind of
reminded me a little bit of like maybe
an early peter jackson movie not as
over-the-top like grotesque as that but
the sense of humor is kind of similar if
you know where i'm coming from
so yeah so this was actually uh alex
dela iglesia's second feature film his
first being the sort of underground cult
classic uh axion mutante
which i never saw it but i remember it
coming out because i remember there
being like a certain subset of
really really cool like film people that
had the t-shirt you know what i mean so
i remember that like or stickers and
stuff so but i never did see the movie
but this was his second uh film
and honestly like he went on much later
i think most recently he did like a hbo
max series called 30 coins which again i
haven't seen uh but you know so so he's
kind of like a big deal you know what i
mean and he was also a producer i hadn't
seen like most of his other movies but
he was a producer on this movie called
uh erimantari which um i saw not too
long ago that was a decent flick and uh
so yeah so definitely but after seeing
this so i've been this has been on my
list for like a really long time because
everybody and honestly on shutter it has
five skulls um everybody's just like oh
my god this is awesome how did i not see
this movie before and i would have to
agree this movie
is
a ton of fun uh as i said it's a black
comedy first but it is quite violent
and it is very
irreverent specifically if you're i mean
obviously it doesn't didn't bother me
any but um you know spain being kind of
like a more leaning toward like being a
catholic country so it's probably was a
lot more irreverent to them like back
then
but i think the humor still translates
uh you know but like i said if you if
you're super religious you'll probably
be offended but i don't imagine that
super religious people would be watching
this so you know it's just that kind of
old situation
so basically what you have here the
setup of this
is there's a basque uh priest uh father
angel or angel i guess you would call it
um or they actually just call him akira
for short
and he is uh you know a priest and a
theology professor
and kind of his life's work apparently
has been deciphering um this code or
something in uh saint john's like the
book of revelation so he's been working
on that for a really long time at the
very beginning of the movie he runs into
this church and says to a fellow priest
hey i figured out this code that i'm
trying to figure out for all this time
and i figured out
that uh it's actually a date and it's
when the antichrist is gonna be born now
it so happens that the antichrist is
going to be born somewhere in madrid on
christmas like dawn of christmas day
1995.
so
what uh the priest decides to do
is that his kind of i guess it's kind of
like a hair brain scheme this is a
bonkers ass movie but it's like it's
super super enjoyable i had a [ __ ]
blast with this one and i just like
laughed out loud so many times it's just
it's almost
like i said it's almost peter jackson's
sam raimi kind of it's not as wacky as
that but it is it does like it have an
element of slapstick and an element of
like black humor to it um so if you like
those filmmakers then you'd probably
really dig this so i guarantee like you
should you should probably check it out
also i think one of the best things
about it too is like the characters like
the interaction between the characters
really really well done the acting in
this is so great uh actually the guy
that plays
the priest
was in i think he was in some guillermo
del toro movies uh now that i'm thinking
about i think he was the doctor and
pan's labyrinth and he was in some other
stuff too but some of these um if you
know anything about kind of
international cinema or anything like a
lot of these actors will be familiar to
you you know uh you know and i'll talk
about that a little bit too like one of
the other characters
so yeah so he's figured out that
antichrist is going to be born so he is
basically like
what i'm going to have to do is i'm
going to have to figure out because he
knows the date of the antichrist being
born but he doesn't know exactly where
he knows going to be somewhere in madrid
but you know obviously madrid is a big
city so he decides that well i'm going
to have to get in good with satan
so i can figure out where the antichrist
is going to be born so i can kill the
antichrist the baby
and uh and then thus prevent the end of
the world so as soon as he tells the
fellow priest that he's gonna do this
and the fellow priest is like oh my god
we totally have to do it this giant
cross like follows and like squishes the
other priest so he's just kind of like
okay so the first part of the movie this
is almost kind of like
it's sort of like in three parts but i
don't know if i necessarily want to say
that like because it's not super overt
but the first part
is he decides i'm gonna have to go and
start doing some sinning so i can get
satan's attention because he's his
reasoning is because i'm a priest i
can't just like ask the devil where the
antichrist is gonna be born he's not to
tell me right because he's because i'm a
priest i'm his enemy
so he decides what he's going to have to
do is he's essentially just going to
have to sacrifice himself sacrifice his
faith sell his soul to the devil so that
the devil will
buy
that he is on his side now and then he
can somehow get the information of where
the antichrist is going to be born he
can like turn on him so that's what he's
going to do so the first part of the
movie is actually just him trying to be
as evil as possible and it's just it
cracks me up so it the first part of
this like cracked me up so much like
seeing this little bitty priest uh you
know in his long
frock or whatever in his little hat and
he's just going through the streets of
madrid which are which are portrayed as
like these ridiculously violent because
there's actually something there's a
through line that goes through the whole
story and ends up kind of um you know
coming full circle at the end of the
movie is that there's all of this uh
there's all these kind of this gang
that's been going through madrid and
they will essentially uh they find like
a homeless person or something they like
beat them to death or set them on fire
alive and then put like clean up madrid
they spray paint it over their body
so that's kind of been going on a lot
and that's kind of been going on in the
background and like i said it ties into
how the story ends so he's walking
through these rough violent streets of
madrid and he's at first just doing
you know shitty [ __ ] things but
nothing like super evil like he'll get
like they'll be like a homeless guy like
sitting there with a you know the cup
full of money and he'll just like take
off the money and like put it in his
pockets uh there's one guy who's like
dying in a car accident and
the cops asked him you know he's just
laying there all [ __ ] up on the hood
and like the cops say you know can you
come give him the last rights and uh he
comes over there steals the dude's
wallet and then like whispers in his ear
i hope you rot in hell like instead of
giving him the last rides so he's doing
stuff like that actually my favorite
thing was when there's like a mime who's
kind of up on this uh you know sort of
stared platform thing like you know
doing the mime thing and the priest just
like pushes
and he falls down the staircase
presumably dies i'm because it looked
like a subway kind of thing so it was
like a long staircase so it's like that
made me laugh really hard so he just
goes around he goes around doing [ __ ]
like that you know so that doesn't
really seem to be getting the attention
of satan uh so he decides the next thing
he does is he goes to this
uh record store which specializes in
like death metal
and this is where he meets jose
jose is my favorite character of this
all the characters of this are so good
like the three uh guys that kind of team
up to try and stop the antichrist are
just like i love every one of them and
it's just like the interplay between the
three of them is just so funny and like
so hilarious but jose's character is so
funny he's kind of like this big heavy
dude this actor uh he was also in some
guillermo del toro i think he was also
in
hellboy
he was in so he's been in like some big
movies i think he was in pacific ram
um you know so he was in some big movies
like later on so he's kind of like this
big dude uh with a beard and he's got
like all these facial piercings and all
his death metal like denim jacket and
everything like that so he owns this uh
you know this shop and the priest goes
in there with this list of like all
these death metal bands and he's like
wanting all this stuff and he's like hey
can you play this now play it backwards
and see if you know what i mean now the
now jose the record store owner kind of
takes a shine to the priest because he's
just like man i like your taste you know
you're pretty cool
and uh he tries to turn him on to like
this local band called satanica who are
playing at this place called hell like
later on so there's that kind of whole
thing now uh so they kind of develop a
friendship and it so happens that the
priest has you know he's come to madrid
and he doesn't really have anywhere to
stay oh he stole somebody else's um
suitcase too that was another thing that
he did well while the guy was out trying
to get a cab like he just took his
suitcase and was like bye so jose tells
him he's like oh my
mom uh owns this like boarding house
type of thing and it's like why don't
you go there if you need a room and
she'll give you a good deal or whatever
so he ends up going there and uh that's
also kind of like a bunch of characters
because jose's mom
ends up just being this like for this
battle axe kind of just herodon type
character and she's like super racist
and she's kind of all this you know it's
like yeah let all these people come in
here and you know because it's kind of a
rough neighborhood so i want to blow
their balls off with a shotgun or
whatever so she's that kind of this
herodon type woman and then jose has a
grandpa who's like this big fat dude who
basically just walks around the house
uh naked all the time and jose keeps him
on lsd to like keep him chilled out
because i guess he has dementia and then
there's this uh younger woman that works
their name i think her name is mina
and she's kind of like you know she's
kind of like the manager made cook type
uh situation she just takes care of the
place and she's kind of younger and jose
is kind of like after her but she's not
having it so uh so he goes there and
kind of checks in and like i said him
and jose developed this friendship jose
of course because he's all into black
metal uh he immediately uh you know is
like oh my god you know the antichrist
yeah we got to do something about that
although he's not super taking it
seriously he's just kind of like oh okay
cool you know heavy he's always saying
so uh so he decides like he's gonna help
the priest out
so uh so you know playing the death
metal backwards and you know pushing
mimes off of staircases really hasn't
been doing much of anything so at this
point uh the priest decides well now we
need an expert
to figure out how to actually sell my
soul and like actually summon satan uh
so we can figure out like what's going
on because the the kind of clock is
ticking i think because it's kind of
like
uh the whole story takes place pretty
much like over like christmas eve and
they have to find where they it where in
madrid the antichrist is going to be
born before dawn because that's when
like the battle of armageddon and like
the end of the world is going to start
so so you know like so it's this takes
place like over one night like over
christmas eve so it's very very
christmasy everybody running around and
there's you know there's all kind of
christmas [ __ ] going on in the streets
like all those christmas lights and
everything
so they decide they need to get an
expert so the expert they get
is this cheese dick tv psychic
he has this show
called i think it's called the dark zone
and his name is professor kavan and he's
just this really really cheesy like he
has like the black mustache and like the
the black clothes and he has like this
ridiculous
necklace like with this hand on it with
all these symbols and it's like it's
just hilarious the dude is like
hilarious and he's obviously
uh a charlatan but he does this show
where it's like you know like look at i
did this exorcism and all this other
stuff it's obviously fake uh and he even
admits like later on that he's full of
[ __ ] but he's written this book about
summoning demons and it comes the
hilarious thing is like it comes in this
kit that has the book and then it has
like the necklace that he wears like it
has one like that except like a cheap
version and uh it has like all these
other little magical kind of things it
almost looks like toys or whatever so he
has this popular show so for whatever
reason the priest thinks well he you
know he has this book and he steals the
guy's book and he's like that guy this
guy knows what he's talking about so we
have to like
get with him and figure out how to
summon satan so he goes to his house
he's like wealthy so he lives in like
this really really nice like high-rise
apartment
and uh so they go to his so he goes to
his house and uh he doesn't want to
cooperate because he's like look i'm
just i'm just doing stupid [ __ ] for the
rooms none of this [ __ ] is real it's
like none of it's gonna work uh so
basically they have to
uh they they essentially end up like
tying him up and pretty much torturing
him like just whacking the [ __ ] out of
him until he agrees to tell them how to
do this magical ritual like to summon
satan
so it has to do so that's like another
kind of farcical kind of situation that
they get into because they don't have
all the stuff it's like you know
consecrated hosts they just have like
some [ __ ] wonder bread or something
and like the priest is like putting the
the thing like the blessing over it it's
like they don't have they needed like
some kind of like psychotropic mushrooms
or something he's like well i have some
tabs of lsd will that work and so they
put that all in there and it's like oh
they need the blood of a virgin so then
the priest has to go find you know try
to get blood from the girl that works at
the boarding house and it's just like
this wacky crazy uh situation of them
trying to gather all the things together
now
at this point uh they get in the circle
like all three of them um i think
they're it's supposed to be because
there's three of them it's supposed to
be kind of like a three wise men type
situation because the priest explains
that well the antichrist is going to be
born because it's supposed to be like
the opposite of jesus being born so you
know there's going to be three wise men
or three stupid men in this situation
which i guess is what they were going
for even though i don't think they say
that out loud but that was kind of like
the implication you know so it's so it's
going to be like exactly the same but
inverted so that's kind of where they're
coming from with that so they do this
the whole ritual
and nothing really happens at first but
then it seems like it worked
uh in the sense that they're all
standing there and at first you don't
think it works because nothing happens
and then they see kind of this bug
crawling across and they're like oh look
the bug couldn't come into the
the circle so that must mean something
and but you know but you're still like
plausible deniability but then like a
black goat comes into the apartment like
with these big [ __ ] things and like
stands up and everything however it
should be noted that when they did the
ritual they took a [ __ ] ton of acid i
mean that was in like i said it was
supposed to be it was the blood of the
virgin and the host and all this other
stuff and they didn't have any
psychotropic mushrooms so they just put
like [ __ ] tabs and tabs of acid in
there so all three of them are tripping
balls
so
um there's a possibility that everything
that happens in the third act of the
movie is
them imagining
uh seeing the devil like all the [ __ ]
that they do
so basically what ends up happening is
like the three of them you know they're
they're struggling to find so the devil
does actually come there or at least
they perceive that like in the form of
the goat
and uh they so they still like to have
to try to figure out so finally uh
professor kavan
thinks that he's figured out
where the antichrist is gonna be born
and it's like this really convoluted
kind of like explanation about you know
the mark of the devil and like there's
these two buildings that are the same
kind of shape and it's just like this
crazy kind of [ __ ] and uh so i don't
really want to spoil the end because i
kind of feel like a lot of people
haven't seen this but i will say
that
this is
i mean this movie was
delightful it was just and i don't know
if everybody's gonna find it as funny as
i did but i found it very very very
funny it's very satirical it's
definitely making fun of
like end times predictions like you know
in movies like the omen and stuff like
that you know people are saying oh the
antichrist and all that kind of stuff
it's definitely making fun of that it's
kind of making fun of stereotypes about
you know people that are into death
metal and [ __ ] like that it's definitely
making fun of
kind of cheesy ass tv psychics who are
sort of like taking advantage of
people's uh gullibility i guess so it's
definitely making fun of that um so it's
just like a funny you know it's making
fun of kind of religion catholicism and
in general i don't know it's not a
mean-spirited movie though it's actually
like quite funny and actually the
friendship particularly between uh the
priest and jose the death metal guy is
actually really kind of sweet you know
what i mean like like he's they're just
very very sweet characters so i mean i
think that's kind of like the heart of
the movie how these three guys like come
together
and uh form this unlikely friendship
because they all start to believe that
this is real and this is really going to
happen and you know we have to stop the
antichrist and as i said i don't
necessarily want to spoil the ending but
remember what i said earlier about like
the gangs that have been roving around
madrid like burning homeless people
alive
uh and [ __ ] like that um that actually
does come into play uh later on in the
movie now as i said the end of it it's
very weird because the end of it was
like kind of abrupt
and it took me a second before i was
just kind of like wait um
what did that mean but then like when i
thought about it and then like i read a
couple more things i was like oh okay
like okay i see what i see what they're
getting at so he it's left ambiguous i
think whether
they actually do
um whether the devil is actually real
and they did actually prevent armageddon
from happening
or
whether everything after the devil
ritual
uh was just them tripping balls because
like i said they did take a whole bunch
of acid so it could just be
that i'm not saying that they didn't do
all of the stuff that they showed them
doing in the movie because they do
but i'm saying their perception of it
might be a lot different
than
than a the sober person's uh perception
of it would be let's put it that way
so
but you know this is um
this is a classic honestly this should
be a movie that people watch every
christmas uh
this is like i saw one reviewer they
call this like the anti-christmas movie
which it kind of is i mean i know that
there's a lot of christmas horror movies
and a lot of them were just like oh you
know evil santa going on a rampage or
something like that this isn't quite
like that because even though it's
christmas
um and the religious aspects of
christmas are being satirized it's more
of a
you know a riff on the omen or on these
kind of like you know end times type of
stories
and honestly the humor in it i found it
very very funny i mean particularly and
like the slapstick violent [ __ ] is funny
like him pushing the mime off the thing
um the one hilarious
fight scene between like him and the uh
and jose's mom like at the boarding
house where she like shoots off part of
his ear and
you know this isn't like chasing her all
around i mean just it's hilarious but it
has other funny [ __ ] in it too it's not
just all like constant slapstick but
that [ __ ] is very funny and and it's
done in a way that's not because
normally i don't like like that real
over the top like zany slap sticky kind
of humor so when i say slapstick i don't
mean it's just like wall-to-wall like
you know three stooges or anything it's
not that crazy but it's really still
funny though and there's still like a
lot of really funny [ __ ] going on there
that's not that just the interactions
with the characters and just the
absurdity of the entire situation is
just so [ __ ] great and i really feel
like uh more people should see this more
people should see it uh as a christmas
movie because it totally is and it's
just it's so so good um the version
that's on i watched the version that's
on shutter as i said it's on several
different streaming services uh for free
so you know there's no reason for you
not to go watch it it's on 2b for free
it's everywhere the only thing i will
say like it came out in 1995 some of the
special effects like the green screen
effects like there's a couple scenes
you know the devil standing up or
there's a couple scenes where they're
climbing where they're tripping balls
and they're climbing around the outside
of this uh high of a high rise like and
try not to fall off and they're all kind
of like uh you know there's all that
kind of stuff so you can see like the
edges of the green screen so it's not
fantastic but you know a lot of movies
that came out in the 90s like low-budget
movies because i think the budget on
this was
maybe 2 million something like that it's
maybe not maybe not even that much but
other than that it's not this isn't a
real special effect heavy
movie so
in a way like the cheap looking effects
like the green screen effects it almost
kind of like adds to the charm i want to
say um just because the characters are
so and like i said it's just such a
wacky
premise
that i mean you can't help but love it
this is a lovable
movie you know what i mean that was one
thing that i was i was like as as
satirical as this is as
as black-hearted as this is
it's all it's just it's still kind of
like charming in a weird way and i'm not
really sure how to explain it unless
you've seen it but i would definitely
recommend it it's a really funny
christmas movie that is not like your
average christmas horror movie type of
thing definitely more of a comedy but it
definitely does have horror elements to
it as well so yeah definitely check out
the day of the beast it's a lot of fun
and i had a really really good time with
it and i feel like more people should
watch it especially around the holiday
season so that will do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye